well i think it's fair to say local
health officials making decisions about
the number of fans allowed back into an
event in las vegas
aren't very popular right now the latest
decision allowing an
outdoor venue only 12 500 fans at an
outdoor speedway that seats 80 000
fans has everybody scratching their
heads the grandstand is nearly a quarter
mile long
and local officials are allowing less
than the governor's 20 percent capacity
the event is sold out but not nearly the
numbers they'd hoped to have
action is this is the first time in my
professional career that i've been
disappointed about having a sellout
uh the southern nevada health district
has
overruled governor sissel act and i
think what
you know we're running up against
something that i think
a lot of municipal municipalities have
run up against and
you've got you've got a lot of
bureaucrats making a lot of
very powerful decisions that i don't
believe they're capable of making
i believe this is a slap in the face of
governor sissel act it's really a sad
day i believe
i was able to have a conversation with
the governor i'll let you ask him what
he thinks of this but
i think it's fairly safe to say that
when the man says 20
and when the southern nevada an agency
in southern nevada
in effect overrules him i think you can
probably guess what he thought about
that